was man in einem aufzug auf keinen fall
machen sollte betriebsfeiern
veranstalten
so bis jetzt geht es hier vor mir wie
kriegen wir gekriegt er dürfe erst die
halbe
stunde lang ist und ihm so scheint es
ist
schade dass das nicht
so sein 40 angibt so die firma
es ist eine großartige leistung und 40
jahren ist sie unsere firma treu
geblieben früher entscheiden
dass diese firma über einen hausmeister
verfügt der stets für einen gut
gefüllten bild hälse und dieser
hausmesse die mein dank gilt
das bin ich
da ist meine damen aufzug auf gar keinen
fall machen sollte geschäfte machen
doch immer im büro ist langweilig man
sieht lang gespräch sind sagt niemann
was mache ich was mache ich bloß da bei
uns ein guter tipp roxio flache fehlen
10 weist dies palast wanderung unter
diesen und genau darin gefallen ihm
eingelassen worden nächsten 14 prozent
euro knackte hund drauf kriegst du fünf
prozent
das auf brauchst du noch original kopie
von rolex größte plus 4 prozent 3
prozent sagen wir zwei prozent ein
prozent der menschen zwölf prozent die
größte was man in einem aufzug nie war
als sonderfall machen sollte
und jetzt immer mehr aufgaben ein ganzes
fressen schon im aufzug meinem ersten
ligen kann dinge über wird schon wieder
zeigt die sparwut in einem nebenberuf
schon wieder an haftplätzen ins heute
gibt es ein huhn aller branchen doch
deren mir zuerst in den insel in den
trotzdem dann kommt kein album drüber
und dann kommt das roomers um
am geruch erkennt man dass dieses tier
schon etwas länger tot ist
da lassen wir den gefiederten freund
einfach dreist und länger im dunkeln und
gibt sich wieder einigermaßen wett und
unbedingt gestand dieses tier ist weiter
vorzubeugen der mann einfach an
gebrauchten knoblauch
ganz wichtig dass man gegen
die übernahme bisland genug lacht der
gebracht der mann etwa so viele denken
wir keinen knoblauch salat und ein
wunderbares knoblauch
gefärbtes hoch
[Applaus]